cavada msaa vous dans une interview
raffolez du melon ouais c'est à dire à
leur petit jeu de mots dans une
interview voilà et il a déclaré qu'à
madame ce que oui effectivement dire non
n'est pas le melon ce serait mentir je
n'ai pas eu le nom ce serait mentir
j'aimerais peut-être pas compte de la
chance que j'avais ta ta ta ta ta voix
lasse et marquer derrière moi pour être
honnête je vais pas faire le bisounours
et elle est très vite peut-être que les
moments je me suis mal comporté je m'en
excuse vous qu'il connaissait dans la
principale vous peut-être s'il voulait
paparazzé vous qui peut être lavé 1001
principal est ce qui effectivement il
est et il est plutôt de la bouée maps
croit il qu'il avait le melon est en
fête hier j'ai parlé avec quelqu'un
qu'il connaît très bien depuis l'enfance
et qu'at il avoué
il dit oui en fait bon moi j'attaque la
la la il aurait dit un peu obligé
d'utiliser le conditionnel
j'attaque la presse people etc mais
finalement je n'oublie pas que quand
même c'est grâce à eux
aujourd'hui on est des stars et là je me
suis vue il n'a pas tant le melon
capable il a été gentil avec toi voilà
il reste il se dit pas que c'est
sûrement qu'il a du talent mais voilà
s'il est bon parce qu'il a du talent
mais en mai il a
le reconnaître parce que c'est pas tout
ce qui leur côté moi je sais que j'ai
connu en 2010 parce qu'il était ami avec
malika ménard qui commençait à peine et
moi je vois l'évolution qu'il a eu la
carrière qu'il a eue c'est un bosseur en
tout cas ça c'est sûr ça c'est un fait
c'est déjà très bien tes copains ne pas
avoir le melon à son âge est un succès
phénoménal très bon c'est comme ça peu
connu qu'une fois par semaine catherine
rambert la chope et c'est pour te dire
c'est à dire que j'aime beaucoup parce
qu'il a mis en scène il a produit mon
beau fils le fils de ma femme et moi ce
qui m'a paru une fois à la vraie
ambiance et de mon beau fils je sais
c'est un peu plus intelligente et
humoriste et je peux vous dire qu'il en
a compris que ça allait mieux s'épanouir
de retrouver le succès un jour de
retrouver le succès un jour une piquette
herman timo connaître lorsqu'il a le
melon à ton fils est elle à los angeles
on sait pas pourquoi ils travaillent pas
audible ça c'est ridicule alors là il
redit je reviens en france mais t'as
fait quoi los angeles des vacances parce
qu'il n'y a pas fait de film qu'on sache
alors il dit je produis ça me jeu
produit à perte affectés pas très bon
[Rires]